welcome back to the stronger by science
podcast the year is 2020 we are
officially in season two of the podcast
and we have an awesome episode today we
start out with an update from the
game-changer cinematic universe we've
got some feats of strength specifically
related to career longevity in a number
of sports we've got some drama related
to some doping rumors in the
weightlifting world we've got a Q&A
segment where we talk about things like
collagen supplementation and muscle
hyperplasia in response to training
we've got a research roundup a Coach's
Corner we talked a little bit about
goal-setting and how to program your
training during a weight loss phase and
Greg also shares some tips on how to
make the perfect homemade caramel so
we've got all that and much much more
it's a very very dense episode with a
lot of information as always thank you
for listening and enjoy welcome back to
the stronger by science podcast this is
now season two of the podcast I am your
host Erik Trexler and for the first
episode of season 2 I'm joined by a
special temporary guest host named Greg
knuckles thanks for having me back thank
you for joining me how was your break it
was good how was yours it was good very
restful um
yeah I enjoyed it spent more time in the
gym suite recovering quite well
whenever I have spare time I like to
just beat the hell out of myself in the
gym senselessly and then I'm like oh
yeah I should probably structure this
yes
had a couple of those workouts that were
just fun and stupid mm-hmm and now
making some gains I feel really good
good deal man yeah
all right so season 2 is here thanks for
everyone for your patience over the
break we had to do all that enjoy the
holidays kind of stuff apologize to our
loved ones for ignoring them for the
last year things like that but we're
back with season 2 ready to go as you
probably know from last season at the
end we we mentioned that we're going to
be doing every other week here and then
we for season two this is gonna last us
basically until the summer then we're
gonna take a little summer break and
then come back with season three now the
tone is
gonna be a little different I think in
season two this is something I haven't
mentioned yet but we do record out of
Greg's home and you now have me
positioned between a middle school
geography B plaque and a Japanese sword
so I feel like it kind of feels like a
really not subtle display of both
intellectual and physical power and I it
feels like the tone in the rooms
different I I feel like you're really
jockeying for a full-time position well
so it was mostly as a bit and then I
realized I'm really bad at framing
camera shot so it didn't work out but a
lot of people have like their degrees
and like certifications and various
qualifications hanging up on the wall
behind them like when they're guests on
podcasts and whatnot I guess you know to
establish expertise or potentially just
to flex one time I was on a podcast with
Laine Norton and he just had a bunch of
guns hanging behind him which honestly
cooler so anyway I was just gonna do
this as a joke went home over the
holidays and my parents saved everything
from my childhood and I wanted to find
like the most random award and like a
recognition plaques that I had from my
youth to hang them up behind me forgot
to get a nail to hang them up but
whatever so the two I got were the 2003
2004 middle school Geography Bee
championship plaque and a basic computer
literacy skills plaque so just want
people to know that I have those things
going for me and then yeah I won a
katana and a powerlifting meet one time
and I think that was Rahl unity won
anyway it's pretty cool so yeah it's
very clear displays of both intellectual
and physical power to hopefully solidify
your place on the podcast so what we'll
see if that subconsciously gets you a
permanent spot
someday I mean I can't hurt can't hurt
that's for sure what one other one other
change to the show that people need to
be aware of is like Eric said we're
moving to a once per two week schedule
I'm gonna take the summer off when we
come back there may or may not be a big
shift in the focus of this show so
depending how the Democratic
presidential primaries go
our American listeners will know this is
election year in the US for foreign
listeners you very well may know that as
well so early on in primary season I was
supporting someone who I thought had a
great chance of winning he seemed to
have a huge organic groundswell of
support and that was Joe Sestak quite
frankly I'm shocked that he has dropped
out already but I've recently gone
all-in for our girl Amy Klobuchar I
think you know I think she basically has
a coin flips chance of taking the
primary and if she does then when we
come back after the summer break this
becomes an Amy Klobuchar political
podcast just to promote her candidacy
yeah and so I'm not sure where I'm gonna
fit into that because I choose my eye
back candidates that I find to be
relatable to me and so you know I grew
up in the Midwest simple kid I
definitely am gonna go with either
billionaire steyr or a billionaire
Bloomberg or billionaire Trump it has to
be a billionaire that I feel like I can
really relate to you know somebody that
is like me in terms of their general
outlook on things so I've narrowed it
down to the billionaire's but I don't
know which one yet so we'll see where I
fall when that comes fair enough
okay little update as listeners know I
have formerly checked out of the
game-changers Cinematic Universe I find
it to be wholly dis interesting but
there is an update there's well there's
many updates the
somehow the universe has survived
without me so dr. Mel Davis has a
write-up on the Renaissance period
ization website as you know I absolutely
refuse to read any more about it but it
did seem good
it's got like a billion references and
yeah so I think they do good work over
there I think she did a really nice job
with it but I didn't read it in its
entirety because I just didn't want to
I'm out of game-changers but if you are
looking for like a good solid look at it
they did it which is awesome because it
means I didn't have to now this is a
less than two hour movie that spurred a
four hour debate which then spurred like
the the Joe Rogan podcast right correct
yeah which then spurred the countless
hundred page articles about either the
movie or the debate and now there is
somebody posted part one of their
analysis of the debate not the movie so
part one of their analysis of the debate
was eight hours long and they said that
the second half was probably going to be
another eight hours long so now we're in
the sixteen our analysis range for again
a film that was less than two hours in
length and I think there's only two
realistic conclusions for the path we're
going down I could see maybe a Ken Burns
miniseries he you know he's very famous
for his Civil War man he said he's done
a lot of very thorough miniseries about
really heavy topics so I'm sure Ken
Burns if he spent a good 24 to 28 hours
on a miniseries
I think we'd finally under turn over
every rock associated with game changers
and the debate following it also George
Lucas is gonna have a lot of time on his
hands the Star Wars thing appears it
sounds like they made the last movie I
don't know I don't really follow it I
mean George Lucas sold the franchise but
I mean so yes he has nothing but time on
his hands yeah so he's he should really
think about doing another like maybe a
nine movie series again but this one
focusing on some of the some of the
topics in game changers so that would be
maybe 26 to 28 our investment but I
think it's gonna go one of those two
directions so stay tuned we'll see what
happens but um whatever happens it'll be
without me cuz I'm out okay let's get to
business Greg we've got important stuff
so first of all we've got feats of
strength do you want to share this one
or should I uh I mean we can just swap
off I guess
cool so even you can start since you're
the one who put this down yeah so I
swooped in with the first feat of
strength because I thought this was
crazy so Vince Carter recently became
the first NBA player to play in four
different decades which we get a lot of
questions on the show about like you
know hey I'm getting into lifting but
I'm kind of like toward the tail end of
my physical peak or whatever you know
any advice for older guys or older women
lifting so I thought this was kinda
relevant and mainly just insanely
impressive so first of all I know that
there are people who are like oh the new
decade doesn't really start until 2021
I'm not interested in that discussion at
all and like it's kind of dumb to be
like you know what was your favorite
year of the 1980s definitely 1990 yeah
yeah like people refer to decades as
like 80s 90s you know one thing I'm
pretty stoked about is now we're back in
the 20s that's that's a decade that
makes sense
so like alts [ __ ] that that's a dumb
name that if teens also doesn't roll off
the tongue but we're back in the 20s
baby it's like the 90s all over again
definitely that's a good decade name and
like you said no one ever says the 20s
barring 2020 and 2030 like that's that's
not how people refer to it for all
practical purposes it's a new decade
deal with it yeah and you said it's like
the 90s again and Vince Carter he made
his debut in the NBA in 1999 when Vince
Carter started playing NBA basketball I
was 7 years old and he still plays he's
lost a step he said he's not he's not
winning the dunk contests anymore bro he
can still throw down yes his minutes
have been reduced
so yeah he doesn't play the same type of
game he used to yeah but there's still
so I I follow the NBA pretty closely and
they're Opie clips from time to time of
just like you know him in the warm-up
lines or like you know after a game or
something of just like him throwing down
a dunk to you know get the crowd going
just do some fanservice
do can still [ __ ] sky yeah like it's
wild he does that with all the 50 year
olds in the stands it reminds them when
they were 11 and started watching
watching him play yeah I mean dude every
Lane so like the thing is he doesn't
have as quick of a first step anymore in
I think just because of how old he is he
probably doesn't really feel safe trying
to go for like a poster in traffic
anymore yeah but I guarantee you if he
gets a juicy fast break he'll turn back
the clock a little bit like dudes dude
still an athletic freak yeah it's it's
awesome it's it's like it's just
phenomenal to have in NBA the NBA is a
tough game oh yeah it takes a toll on
your body which is why he's he's the
only one doing this you know I mean it's
really impressive now this got us on a
little tangent of looking at other
people who have had really long careers
in in professional sports so Tom Brady
almost did the same for decades stretch
but like I mentioned Vince Carter played
his first game in 1999 Tom Brady started
in 2000 so unless he's got another like
nine or ten years in him I don't think
he's gonna span the decades the same way
but but I mean he's started basically
the same time playing pro football
quarterback and really only had one year
that was really impacted by injury I
mean he got his knee rolled over and
missed a season with the ACL tear but
he's at a remarkable career with
longevity probably cuz he doesn't need
tomatoes we should we should talk about
the Tom Brady diet on the podcast at
some point someday that was a joke
everybody follow some weird nutritional
practices and stuff like that like
honestly dude
he doesn't eat alliums he doesn't eat
like garlic and onions if you could tell
me you know you're gonna be arguably the
greatest quarterback ever not really
interested in having that discussion but
it's he's easily in the discussion I
think any everyone would say that yeah
you could be arguably the greatest
quarterback ever make like [ __ ] four
hundred million dollars over the course
of your career whatever like he has but
the catch is you can never eat onions or
garlic I don't know that I would take
that deal honestly you know it's it's
tough it's it's one of those really good
debates which D which door do you go
through I don't know I'd probably take
the Tom Brady route but but it's at
least a good discussion now there are
some other people who have before ever
really dry for content when we you know
we can have the debate here out both
sides yeah that's the controversy that
that would be an excellent four hundred
million dollars or garlic yeah that'd be
a great debate but you found a few other
people who had some pretty pretty
impressive careers in terms of longevity
yeah so on the NFL side of things the
person who still holds the record for
the longest NFL career is George Blanda
he was a quarterback and kicker from
1949 to 1975 I I was honestly a little
surprised by this
I thought the longest career was Morten
Andersen or one of the Anderson's like
back in the 80s and 90s there were two
really good Anderson kickers and I think
Morton was the one that played the
longest I really thought he had the
longest career but when looking into
this it was it was Blanda and just just
think about like the time that that
spans 1949 which is like barely post-war
pre start of Korean War I feel very
American like dating things based on
their proximity to two different wars
but whatever it is what it is and then
ending in 1975 like that's crazy
on the baseball side of things
longest career ever 27 seasons for Nolan
Ryan Nolan Ryan man he he was a
different breed like his strikeout
record I don't think anyone's ever gonna
touch it
so he pitched 27 seasons through I think
seven perfect game or seven no-hitters
and I think the next most by anyone is
like three ish starting pitcher throwing
like hundred to two hundred and four
mile an hour heat when like you know
that's basically reserved for closers
and no one else but his strike his
career strikeout total was fifty-seven
hundred and fourteen career strikeouts
the next closest is Randy Johnson who
was also another incredible strikeout
artist with great longevity his
strikeout total was forty eight hundred
and seventy five so there's like almost
a nine hundred strikeout gap between the
two of them and the next closest active
player is barely over 3,000 so CC
Sabathia and Justin Verlander barely
have over 3,000 I think CC is basically
done Verlander dude Verlander still
throwing hard um
he's so incredible but is he going to
have another how much would that be
another like Jesus Christ basically have
to double up well he basically need
another 14 200 strikeouts seasons Jesus
Christ
anyway Nolan Ryan incredible and then
probably the craziest one of all but
kind of on a technicality is Gordie Howe
hockey player so you know I'm sure all
of our Canadian listeners know all about
Gordie Howe and virtually no one else
but he played in six decades he came
into the league in 1946 played until
1980 between the NHL and the World
Hockey Association and then
he got picked up for one game which I
don't know all of the details around
this I assume it was just like a
promotional thing to get butts in the
seats but he got picked up for one game
for the Detroit Vipers in the
International Hockey League which is
still a professional organization like
he was still like he signed a monetary
contract for it in 1997 so officially
his playing career stretched from 1946
to 1997 and the last game when he laced
up a pair of skates and keep in mind not
in the NHL anymore like in a lesser
hockey league but like hockey still a
tough sport like people can still light
you up he played that last game at the
ripe old age of 69 dude if I'm 69 I'm
gonna think twice before I shovel my
driveway yeah like to be on a
professional to be on a professional
hockey rink Lee yeah I mean I I assumed
that people were like hey don't don't
crush don't crush Gordie like I hope I
mean if I took hockey as seriously as I
take like sports science I would have
actually done more research about this
because it very well could have been a
thing where like he signed a contract
he took one skate around the ice for
three minutes and like came back off I
don't know it could have been something
like that but I mean it just
theoretically and played his last
professional game in 1980 and was
presumably at least somewhat in skating
shape 17 years later yeah I mean it's
crazy
even without that that game in 1997 I
mean to play out of my life records from
46 to 1980
yeah that's insane so you know we get
that question all the time from people
like hey you know I'm getting into
lifting I'm 41 I'm 48 like you know how
should I train what do you think and
it's it's just awesome to see people out
there doing this stuff competing at a
high level way late into their career
like that it's really really impressive
now we don't have any other feats of
strength just throwing that
there so I mean it was the holidays
there aren't that many meats like right
over Christmas
or the holiday season I suppose because
you know most people are traveling doing
stuff with family so yeah I mean I
looked I looked into it there were some
people who have gotten stronger hit some
PRS like I think John hack recently hit
squat PR in a bench PR which you know
that's cool but no like crazy World
Records or anything just wild recently
so that is why we led into or that's why
we led with various professional
athletes with super long careers yeah
another thing is like we do have a great
deal of influence in the various
strength related pursuits we did kind of
send out an email in December we said
hey we're gonna power down the podcast
over the holidays if you hit any PRS
we're not gonna be discussing them so
you might want to just everybody chill
for a while so I think a lot of people
just out of respect for the show just
kind of tone things down a little bit I
would I would like to think that's how
it went all right now this is not feats
of strength related but it's still quite
fascinating so why don't you die I don't
even know how to intro to this you just
dive in yeah so we'll just call this
segment the drama segment even though I
guess like all of the just mass
game-changers related media that's kind
of drama I guess sure but then this
relates to I'm sure we've any
weightlifting feat of strength that
we've shared I mean yeah yeah yeah all
of it yeah exactly
so there was a German documentary which
translates in English to Lord of the
lifters that came out recently so in the
interest of full transparency I speak a
little bit of German not much certainly
not enough to watch an entire
documentary and understand more than
maybe 30% of it so I'm going off of a
summary post
on all things gym we can leave leave
that in the show notes for anyone else
who you know wants to make sure that I'm
representing their account of it
correctly and most importantly for my
interests you are not making these
claims correct you are simply reporting
on an article correct perfect that's
what my lawyers told told us to say yes
so what I have heard is that there is
going to be an English translation of
this documentary coming out soon when
that occurs I will definitely watch it
but for the time being I'm going off of
the all the all things Jim recap of it
so like I said translated Lord of the
lifters and so essentially it is
alleging massive fraud and corruption by
by the International weightlifting
Federation and interestingly the iwf
isn't flatly denying it they're saying
that basically they know about some of
the stuff that was reported and they
think some of it's incorrect but there
is like new stuff in the documentary
that was recently brought to their
attention so before I get into what the
documentary is actually saying this was
the iwf statement about it
so they said amid a number of apparent
falsehoods unsubstantial yet
unsubstantiated allegations and
disproven rumors dating back to as far
as 2008 there does seem to be some fresh
information included in the program
which may be abuse to the ida wfs
efforts to promote clean weightlifting
and protect clean sport the IWF will
move very quickly to investigate the
issues raised in the show as quickly as
possible and has requested the
transcripts and research material the
IWF takes these allegations very
seriously and where appropriate will
consider independent third party
assistance and investigating these
matters so what I'll say about that is
if like if we assume that the stuff in
the documentary is correct I don't know
that in iwf internal investigation will
actually accomplish anything
but I do think it's telling that they're
not just like completely repudiating it
out outright so anyway what what what is
being alleged in this documentary is as
follows so they start by just generally
discussing the drug problem in
weightlifting weightlifting has a higher
rate of positive drug tests than any
other Olympic sport that may or may not
mean actually higher rates of drug use
I'm sure that it is among the highest
rates of drug use for all Olympic sports
you know like cycling may be higher or
at least probably was higher back in the
heyday but you know easier to test for
anabolics an EPO but that's you know
that's another discussion but at least
in terms of rates of returning positive
tests weightlifting is worse than any
other Olympic sport one of the things
they talked about here which I was
completely unaware of is that from 2008
to 2017 half of all medalists in Olympic
and World competitions in weightlifting
weren't drug tested I thought that there
was just an automatic policy of if
you're on the podium you get tested I'm
pretty sure that's how it is in
powerlifting and I assumed more people
got tested in weightlifting but at least
this documentary is saying that half of
the medalists from OSA from Oh 8 to 2017
weren't tested and two-thirds of Russian
medalists weren't tested which is inter
interesting given their their history of
doping is one of the other allegations
made is that in training basically like
you want to see a certain number of out
of meet tests to you know basically
because if you're only testing in
contests people can just cycle off and
beat the tests so one of the allegations
made is essentially that like the IWF
will drug test people like the top
lifters when they're way far out of
competition but will intentionally not
test them in the months like in the
months immediately leading up to big
meats so they can still show up and like
hit big numbers set world records and
get the sports impress one of the other
things they talk about is the
organization that the IWF uses for its
drug testing so essentially if there is
a weightlifting meet held in the United
States that is saying sanctioned by the
American weightlifting body it's going
to use you sada for testing for
international meets the IWF generally
covers the testing instead of the host
country and they use an organization
called who not o hu in a do and one of
the allegations made in the documentary
is that who natto is is possibly /
probably covering for lifters who are
using gear one of the data points they
bring up is like if you were following
weightlifting in 2015
worlds were held in the u.s. I believe
Houston that year and you sada the
United States anti-doping agency was
very insistent that they wanted to
handle the testing for that meet since
it was gonna be on US soil
they basically said this is our
jurisdiction we don't really trust you
guys we want to be the ones doing the
drug testing and 2015 worlds had a
higher rate of in contests positive
tests than any other like world or
Olympic meet ever I think
if memory serves there were 24 positives
out of that meet either 24 18 it was
some reasonably large number though
which was way more than than other meet
so like 2008 Olympics for example a lot
of people have got popped on retests but
they didn't get popped with like the
immediate test that came back right
after the Olympics 2015 Worlds was a
bloodbath
like the immediate results of in contest
drug tests tons of people got popped
possibly because you sada was testing
and not who not
so they get into it a little bit more
they interview someone who who they said
and I think probably is the national
team doctor for the Moldova
weightlifting team and that individual
claimed that if you natto is testing
your lifters leading up to a meet or in
a meet you can just pay the person who's
collecting the samples 60 bucks if it's
a national meet are two hundred bucks if
it's an international meet if you want
the test to come back clean which that
is quite the allegation because the
thing is like dude if you're allowing
corruption and you're allowing people to
like buy clean tests you would think
that that the pound of flesh would be
bigger than 200 bucks you would
definitely think so yeah but anyway that
is the allegation made by the Moldova
team doctor one of the other things they
they discuss going back to 2015 worlds
is that cuñado was doing out of meat
testing for a lot of the athletes
leading up to Worlds and tested a bunch
of them in like the month or so before
competition and for quite a few of those
athletes they're in competition sample
when theoretically they cycled off and
would have the greatest chance of of
passing a drug test you sought I tested
them came back positive and it very much
looked like you know you were using
stuff in the past like a month or so you
almost got it out of your system but we
have sensitive tests and we can detect
some of these metabolites so like
several weeks ago or a month ago you
would have had a lot more [ __ ] in your
system and it would have been way easier
to detect you natto did testing during
that time period and said a lot of those
people were clean when they necessarily
must have had more stuff in their system
unless counter scandal
maybe you sada is throwing people under
the bus who aren't actually using that's
a joke I don't think they're actually
doing that it wouldn't surprise me if
like the Russian minister of sport says
that
something though and then so another
person they interviewed is a guy named
Hans Geiger who is a wada accredited
german drug tester or works for a wad
accredited accredited laboratory and he
just straight-up said that they knew
that some people were passing out of
contest drug tests because who nada was
letting people basically submit
fraudulent urine like you know you come
in the person who you're actually
supposed to drug test is so new when I
was talking about like the 60 or $200 to
to pass a drug test the system in place
apparently is basically they will
collect the wrong persons urine if
you're willing to pay a fee because
there is still that database there needs
to be those samples like on file and so
if they just you know straight up didn't
collect a sample that would be
suspicious or if they collected the
correct sample and said it's clean and
then they retest it and it's dirty as
hell that would also be suspicious so
apparently the system in place is like
you pay 200 bucks and then like your
buddy who doesn't use anything pees in
the cup for you and so Hans Geiger is
saying like yeah we know for sure
they're doing this because analyzing
their biological passport and in some
cases DNA we know for sure that these
samples that were being collected aren't
actually from the athletes they're
supposed to correspond to so he's like
corroborating that part of the story
let's see and then the documentary
shifts to Thailand they talked to a Thai
female lifter who I think I think her
story is she placed fourth at the
Olympics one year wasn't tested and at
least one of the people ahead of her got
popped on retest and so she officially
has a bronze medal now I think that was
her back story but anyway she was at
least like a top four top five lifter in
her weight class
she admits to basically doping her
entire professional weightlifting career
I think from the time she was 18
onward she talked about doping within
the Thai weightlifting system talking
about how people like athletes as young
as 13 are already being put on gear to
be able to compete internationally and
in her account she was basically like
look I know I was on drugs I had nothing
to do with it my coach and the team
doctor you know were the ones handling
the protocols to make sure I got the
stuff I needed and that it would be out
of my system to where I could pass tests
turns out her coach during that time
period is now the IWF vice president did
she name him like by name in the
documentary I think so okay Wow
yeah and so also keep in mind here's
someone who like you know maybe it'll
come out that there was like shady
business going on and people like paid
her off to give false testimony or
something but this at least looks very
credible on the surface because this is
an individual who competed her entire
career one of the best in the world
never failed a drug test admitting that
she used drugs the whole time which what
how how will that do anything except
tarnish her legacy you know and still
being willing to say this stuff on
camera so that's certainly interesting
and then so that's all of the doping
related stuff there were further
allegations related to financial
corruption cash payment for bribes to
top idea of WWF officials having secret
bank accounts to collect those cash
bribes and like hide them away from like
auditors and tax people and then also
possible tax fraud so the the corruption
allegations made in this documentary a
lot of them related to doping and the
IWF like possibly covering for dopers
and turning a blind eye to it but there
was like a whole other part of the
documentary related to financial
corruptions
which i think is probably less relevant
to the podcast and I personally just
care less about um but related to that
side of things they interviewed a guy
markeith or pipe P ie th who was one of
the investigators for the recent FIFA
scandal which if he followed that it was
pretty bad
like pretty ugly and this guy at least
claims that the financial corruption he
has seen looking into the iwf case is
much more brazen than even what he saw
with FIFA and so I mean here here's kind
of my take on the whole thing so like I
said this is a documentary which may or
may not be biased may or may not be
truthful seemingly the IWF isn't
dismissing it out of hand which I think
at least counts for something but I mean
my take on it is like let's say it a
quarter of this is true it's still
[ __ ] bad you know yeah so I at this
point don't have that much faith in the
iwf to actually carry out a clean and
legitimate internal investigation cuz
the thing is like if there is corrupt as
this documentaries alleging what do we
think they're gonna do come back and say
like yep it's alright we're the crooks
here like they're not they're not gonna
[ __ ] do that but yeah I'm very
interested to see how all of this plays
out the worst case scenario and I kind
of think the most likely scenario is
that weightlifting is toast
like it will carry on but there have
already been threats to remove
weightlifting from the Olympics mainly
related to all of the positive drug
tests that do already happen if it turns
out there should be a [ __ ] ton more that
the actual governing body for the sport
is covering for their [ __ ] toast like
they're dead in the water and more
relevant to my interests which is
power lifting there are a lot of people
out there who are still like clamoring
for an expecting power lifting to get
into the Olympics and here's my humble
opinion if weightlifting gets the boot
for this stuff like primarily drug stuff
there's no way in hell powerlifting is
ever getting in as I understand it there
had there were already kind of talks to
remove weightlifting just simply because
like it's not nearly as popular as a lot
of the other sports in the Olympics it
doesn't draw the viewer numbers etc and
so like I say this as someone who loves
powerlifting and who has tried
weightlifting and sucked at it and then
it particularly like it
I think weightlifting is a more
enjoyable spectator sport than
powerlifting hands down so I mean you
know if there's an issue of public
interest and just like what's going to
draw a viewer numbers they're not gonna
put powerlifting in if weightlifting was
already on the rocks there and then if
the issue is like drug problems like
dude powerlifting also has drug problems
and also has a lot of people like has
high rates of positive tests even with
laxer doping controls than weightlifting
has so yeah if they kick weightlifting
out for any of that stuff powerlifting
is never getting in within our lifetimes
yeah so just to recap German documentary
I think it's coming out in English soon
that's what I've seen people saying and
like I said if even a fraction of the
allocations in it are true it is a bad
look for the iwf so Greg you know you
know me I'm a scientist so it's
important for me to have a certain level
of evidence before I make a conclusion
so absolutely a documentary that's very
interesting it sounds like they have
some credible witnesses but what it's
gonna take for me to really form an
opinion on this is I want to see a
debate that's twice as long as the movie
and then I want to see a discussion
the debate that is four times longer
than that and once I have that
information available then I'll feel
ready to really have an opinion no I
think that's perfectly understandable
that's the standard so okay let's move
on so listeners know we're going to
every other week with episodes which
means the Q&A episodes are kind of
getting folded in and merged into the
regular ones so we've got a couple Q&A
questions more than a couple but Greg
why don't you throw me the first one
from Andy tea here you got it so Andy
tea asks what is the best way to achieve
slash plan for lifting goals going into
the new year for example if I want to
increase my bench from 260 to 315 I'm
assuming kilos I hope so yeah
you know so people who are in people who
have heard this before gonna roll their
eyes because it's kind of cliche but
it's also good advice so if you go into
this and you say like my goal is to
increase my my bench by what is that
like fifty five pounds that's not a
particularly effective goal the the
acronym that everybody uses with goal
setting like I said kind of cliche but
pretty pretty useful is setting what
they call SMART goals so specific
measurable attainable relevant and
time-bound and so when it says relevant
basically what that means is that the
goal you're setting actually aligns with
your broader goals and is truly
important to you is it relevant now is
there I I learned realistic and I always
thought that it was incredibly redundant
we're at attainable or achievable so I
mean if if the powers that be have
changed that too relevant
I still think like no [ __ ] it should be
something you actually want to do why
why else are you setting the goal in the
first place but I would appreciate the
change just to reduce redundancy so
there are multiple versions of the smart
acronym and I combine the ones that I
thought weren't stupid so fair enough
yeah so you'll see different kind of
adaptations of this but this is the
clustering of
of words that I think make the most
sense and and you'll see people use us
in a variety of different fields and
they adopt it kind of based on what
they're going for but but as you
mentioned realistic it is often part of
it sometimes that gets lumped in as
attainable or achievable which makes
sense it's critical to be realistic with
your expectations which means being
honest and proactive about your barriers
to achieving that goal and one way to go
about doing that is to have smaller kind
of intermediate checkpoint goals and
that in my opinion is what makes
relevant a really key factor here so
like I said if you just say that the
entirety of your goal is I want to
increase my bench by fifty five pounds
that's a good goal but in terms of like
what you're going for like that'd be
awesome but that's not an effective goal
in terms of the parameters that you've
set sometimes it helps to have smaller
intermediate goals that are relevant to
your broader goal so and again they have
to be time bound so maybe instead of
saying I want to increase my bench fifty
five pounds you say within the next 12
weeks I want to increase it by 15 pounds
or something like that you start sending
these intermediate check points now in
many cases your smart goal might not
actually be your actual goal but rather
a plan to combat or work against your
largest barrier so maybe your your goal
deep down is I want to increase my bench
press 55 pounds but maybe your barrier
your keep you keep running into is that
you continue to skip workouts so if your
goal is to have like a really high bunch
you're probably not skipping workouts
but but just in general here sometimes
you look at the barrier that's your
biggest challenge and you say well okay
I know that my goal is I want to lose 15
pounds but the SMART goal I'm gonna set
is for the next 12 weeks I'm gonna get
into the gym at least three days a week
or something like that so it's relevant
to the true end goal but it's more
specific it's more measurable and for
you right now it is more attainable or
achievable right it's something that you
have a lot more autonomy and control
over now some people when it comes to
goal-setting
they prefer really small changes that
are more gradual in nature some people
prefer really drastic over
hall's when it comes to that it really
comes down to knowing yourself so if you
set a really really small goal that's so
attainable that it doesn't even get you
excited or interested that might not be
effective because you might be so
apathetic about it you're like and
whatever some people prefer to say like
no this is it we are entering a really
specific enthusiastic phase here and
we've got this goal but like I said the
most important thing it's got to be
specific enough that you can keep
yourself accountable it's got to be
measurable so that you can be objective
about it it has to be attainable or
achievable it's got to line up with your
broader goals and you have to have a
time limit on it
I really think those are the key aspects
to setting a good goal where you can
hold yourself accountable and really
have an objective assessments about
whether or not you're on pace and
whether or not you have really
successfully completed it I agree
okay we've got a question from Matt
Ellison the conventional wisdom seems to
be that individual fibre hypertrophy
plays a much larger role in muscle
hypertrophy than hyperplasia
so basically hypertrophy is what is
really underlying muscle growth rather
than hyperplasia
I think it's funny how how totalizing
that concept is just from the wording of
the question fibre hypertrophy plays a
much larger role in muscle hypertrophy
than hyperplasia right hypertrophy
completely explains hypertrophy like
it's free identity property so he's
saying like a much larger role in total
change in muscle size yeah but yeah I
mean the idea that hypertrophy is really
the only thing going on has become so
common that hypertrophy has loop has
become literally synonymous with change
in muscle size right I find interesting
just from a linguistic perspective yeah
yeah it's true and so that the question
continues it seems like we don't have
much control over hyperplasia is anyone
looking into how we can boost
hyperplasia or maybe our overall
hypertrophy potential so again using
hypertrophy I think as a proxy for
muscle growth yeah yeah so that's a
that's a good question
and the answer to the actual question
being asked is very straightforward is
anyone looking into how we can boost
hyperplasia no they aren't I am not
aware of a single active line of
research interested in that but what I
will say is so the this question
basically seems to be assuming possibly
that hyperplasia doesn't occur or that
if it does occur it's kind of trivial
and that hypertrophy or change in fiber
size plays a much larger role and so I
just kind of want to rant about
hyperplasia a little bit because that is
the that's the common line basically
that muscle growth occurs due to fiber
hypertrophy and maybe some expansion of
like connective tissues and other stuff
but basically fiber hypertrophy is is by
far the main driving factor and I
learned in undergrad X phys and I think
you said you did as well that
hyperplasia doesn't occur in humans that
muscles get bigger because fibers get
bigger and that's that you don't get
more fibers and honestly I just don't
buy that that's what I learned that's
what I believed and then when I started
looking into the research a bit more I
started getting more skeptical of that
and I think what kind of cemented it for
me is Jose Antonio wrote a really good
article about hyperplasia for the ISSN
blog a while ago maybe like four or five
years ago which laid out a lot of the
evidence which I personally think is is
pretty convincing so you know for
starters people do claim that
hyperplasia doesn't occur in humans
because it has never been directly
observed in humans I want to be upfront
about that but and this is a big but the
reason it hasn't been directly observed
in humans is you can't do the
experiments in humans you would need to
do in order to observe hyperplasia so
basically to
measure like a count for hyperplasia
that requires counting muscle fibers and
counting all of them so in like a mouse
study say that measures hyperplasia to
actually count how many muscle fibers
there are you have to kill them you have
to kill the mouse and then like if
you're looking at say the hamstrings or
whatever you would cut its entire
hamstring muscle off and then like I
think you you transect it at the midway
point and then just basically get under
a microscope and start countin so like
you're never gonna do that study in
humans so until there's some sort of
non-invasive way to count all of the
fibers in a muscle which I don't even I
don't even know if that's technically
possible it's certainly not possible
with current technology but until
there's a way to do that it will never
be observed in humans because we can't
apply the correct experimental
techniques to be able to observe it but
what I will say is that essentially
researchers have been able to observe
hyperplasia in every context that
they've tried to so the most the most
famous hyperplasia studies were the bird
stretch studies where they'd essentially
put weights on bird's wings which would
like place a stretch on the muscles that
like keep the wings like retracted and
pulled up and using models like that
they found just absolutely ridiculous
both hypertrophy and hyperplasia
so like total change in muscle size of
like something close to 200 percent in a
matter of weeks and you know that was
like individual fibers getting twice as
big and like 60% more total muscle
fibers so like those studies are wild
but they've also used like much more
reasonable interventions in mice and in
cats where like basically it's just this
sort of resistance training that humans
would do so they can like
a mouse up to an apparatus that like
makes them squat and if they don't squat
they like shock their feet and that like
induces them to squat and stand back up
and so with like you know reasonable
training frequencies and loads they were
able to induce hyperplasia in mice with
training that looks very similar to like
human resistance training similar story
with cats so like I don't know if if it
was one of those things where like let's
say they tried to find high perch or
hyperplasia in three different animals
and really had only panned out with the
avian stretch studies then I'd be like
okay like maybe you have a point maybe
with like normal type exercise and in
non avian species maybe we're not seeing
hyperplasia but you know they found it
in three different animals now using a
variety of different protocols and two
of those were mammals so I don't know
why one would assume hyperplasia doesn't
occur in humans and on the human side of
things there is some indirect evidence
that hyperplasia occurs so there was a
pretty famous study by MacDougall in 82
where essentially they had they
recruited untrained people and they
trained them for six months and they
compared the various muscle fiber
characteristics and in performance
outcomes and whatnot for the the
untrained subjects versus the same
subjects after six months of training
versus a sample of power lifters and
bodybuilders who were you know quite
jacked and had a considerable amount of
training experience and in that study
they found that muscle fiber size was
similar between the individuals who
trained for six months and the power
lifters and bodybuilders who'd been
training for years and years and so like
there's two possible interpretations
there one is just that you know people
start with different numbers of muscle
fibers the total number of muscle fibers
you start with maybe constrains the
amount of muscle growth that can take
place and you know maybe people who
drawn to strengthen physique sports are
just people who are born with more
muscle fibers and thus more muscle
growth potential and I think that that's
a strong possibility and I think that
that that partially explains the results
but the other thing I'll say is like
people don't stop growing at six months
like maybe you're really coming close to
approaching your genetic potential after
five years ten years I mean yeah some
growth probably occurs between five and
ten years but things are progressing
pretty slowly by that point but you know
you're not to the point of just barely
eking out gains at the six-month point
like you virtually everyone can still
grow a considerable amount more after
just six months of training so I I find
it unlikely that the previously
untrained subjects in the mcdougal study
you know now have fibers as big as the
strength athletes and bodybuilders and
thus are super elite and will have a
hard time growing more so you know would
they end up with just fibers way bigger
than the bodybuilders and power lifters
maybe I kind of doubt it competitive
strength athletes and bodybuilders are
generally pretty good at getting most of
the growth that they're going to get so
I kind of think that as training age
increases hyperplasia starts playing a
larger and larger role in the total
muscle growth that takes place that's
just a hunch okay and then moving on
more indirect human evidence there was a
study looking at basically counting
fiber numbers in the tibialis anterior
of dead people you know like people died
donated their bodies to science and
someone wanted to like look into this
and so they I believe it was the
tibialis anterior they just cut it off
and just count fibers between the
dominant and non-dominant sides and so
apparently your non-dominant to the
Allis anterior gets more work than your
dominant side tibialis anterior which
kind of makes sense cuz like you know if
you're like kicking stuff I guess
your non-dominant leg is gonna be your
plant leg and I guess tibialis interior
would be involved in that if you're like
throwing stuff that's like the leg
absorbing the shock of the landing from
the throw so I can buy that and if
memory serves in that study the the
subjects had like 13% more total fibers
in their non-dominant tibialis anterior
compared to their dominant side and you
know possible explanations one maybe it
was just sampling bias that's always
possible to maybe just as like the body
is choline muscle fibers there's some
way that the brain senses what dominant
and non-dominant side is going to be and
Cole's more muscle fibers on the
non-dominant
on the dominant side and so you're just
born with more muscle fibers on your
non-dominant tibialis anterior that
seems like a stretch to me but that's a
possible interpretation or what I think
the most likely interpretation is is
just that just from activities of daily
living and using your non-dominant
tibialis anterior more some hyperplasia
occurs and you wind up with more fibers
so yeah you know that's not causal
evidence but it's more indirect evidence
suggesting that hyperplasia very well
may occur in humans so like I said I'm
of the camp that certainly during the
early stages of muscular development
fiber hypertrophy plays you know the
definitely dominant role explaining
changes in muscle size but I do kind of
think that as your training career
progresses one I'm I'm quite convinced
that hyperplasia occurs and then to
first say someone who has five years of
training experience and they're still
growing slowly but surely there's a part
of me that kind of thinks that
hyperplasia plays a pretty meaningful
role in continued muscle growth
one of the concepts I've talked about on
the podcast before is that like surface
area to volume
relationships are a big factor in all
across biology like the that's a main
constraint and cellular metabolism and a
bunch of different [ __ ] and so like I
think that I think that that is probably
at least puts a soft cap on fiber growth
just as fibers get larger and larger
diffusion distances for oxygen and waist
clearance get larger and larger and I
think that that kind of constrains how
big individual fibers can get and maybe
they start approaching that level you
know after a matter of months or a
couple years rather than five or ten
years and so you know past that point
maybe there is still some hypertrophy to
occur but maybe continued growth is
maybe more hyperplasia driven you know
not saying that it accounts for 80% of
new growth but I think it's it's at
least like a non-negligible contributor
you know maybe it's 10% maybe it's 30%
maybe it's 80% I don't [ __ ] know but
I think that it probably I personally
think it likely plays a non-negligible
role in ongoing total muscle growth so
yeah and like I said to answer your
question initially I know one is looking
into how to boost hyperplasia because
it's kind of like I think my view is the
heretical one I think most people still
kind of think it doesn't occur so why
why spend time and research dollars
trying to develop a line of research
investigating something that a lot of
your field thinks is a myth that
wouldn't be a way to win awards and get
promoted so definitely would not see
yeah no one no one's looking into it
but I personally think that it occurs
and probably to a relevant degree in
trained lifters alright so this next
question it looks like it's from a
really dedicated listener here yeah so
question from reps for Jesus which very
cool for your parents to name you that
hell yeah so reps for Jesus asks does
collagen or glycine supplementation
provide any benefit to connective tissue
muscle or skin beyond simply increasing
protein quantity yeah it's a good
question I wrote about this in Mass a
couple months back and I gotta be honest
when I when I first started looking into
it I I kind of was skeptical about
college and supplements for no specific
reason it was just one of those things I
heard about it I was like ah I doubt it
but looking into it you know sometimes
that's kind of like my starting position
oh yeah for sure things yeah
but looking into it there there actually
is some pretty nice evidence so starting
out at the beginning here collagen is a
very abundant protein in the body the
most abundant protein and obviously it
plays really important roles in bone
tendon cartilage and muscle tissue now
when when we do any kind of mechanical
loading running jumping lifting it
stimulates collagen turnover in these
tissues and so we need to increase our
collagen synthesis to basically maintain
the strength and integrity of these
tissue so most studies when it comes to
looking at collagen suppliments we're
looking at usually bone and tendon
turnover as the key things and then some
you know downstream effects on the
structure or function of joints so the
idea with collagen supplementation or
gelatin supplementation which is very
similar is that they provide the raw
materials needed to support this
increased collagen synthesis obviously
collagen is made of a specific sequence
of amino acids and if you take a
collagen or gelatin supplement you are
providing those raw materials and ample
quantities the reason that the question
includes glycine is because there is
reason to think that glycine is kind of
one of the key limiting amino acids in
that it's kind of like the leucine of
tendons that's a very specific metaphor
I wouldn't go that far but but it does
tend to be the one that you'd be less
likely to get from other sources in the
diet that I got you could be rate
limiting okay yeah
it's not like it doesn't have like a
specific initiation yeah it doesn't kick
off analog of the mTOR pathway or
anything like that yeah so you know
looking through some of the research on
it there was a study by Shaw and
colleagues in 2017
they gave a vitamin C enriched gelatin
supplement before six minutes of jumping
rote jumping rope and they did find an
enhancement of collagen synthesis post
exercise there's a study by Clark and
colleagues all the way back in 2008
where they gave 10 grams of collagen to
a big group of collegiate athletes
actually for 24 weeks and they did find
some statistically significant
improvements in a variety of outcomes
related to joint pain in 2011 there was
a study by McClendon at all and they
looked at the effects of college and
supplementation on cartilage thickness
specifically in people with arthritic
conditions so they did find a
statistically significant increase in
cartilage thickness but it's a little
bit questionable whether or not that
that truly is going to translate over to
people with non arthritic or non
arthritic populations
the most recent study I've seen on call
or one of the more recent ones was by
curve C at all in 2019 probably 99%
chance I'm pronouncing that name wrong
but they were looking at recreationally
active men they were doing resistance
training it was a 24 week study where
they were given some collagen peptides
as a supplement and what they found was
an increase in fat free mass I believe
they used DEXA for that measurement but
they found no in they found no change in
muscle fiber cross-sectional area so the
the author's interpretation of those two
finding was was that maybe there is an
increase in connective tissue mass
rather than muscle mass itself so taken
together I mean there's certainly some
evidence to suggest that supplementing
with either gelatin or collagen may may
have some positive effects related to
collagen synthesis notably you're gonna
want to make sure that it is combined
with vitamin C so vitamin C plays a
really key role in the process of
collagen synthesis and so if you put all
these amino acids in
mixture there but you don't have
sufficient vitamin C intake along with
that environment it's not gonna be
helpful you want to make sure yeah
that's why not getting enough vitamin C
causes scurvy yep
vitamin C if memory serves is a cofactor
for the rate limiting step of collagen
synthesis and man scurvy is wild so
should I go off-script I mean how far
off script you go it's like reasonably
off script but it's a it's a fun little
tidbit about scurvy yeah sure yeah so
scurvy was a massive problem at the
start of the Age of Exploration because
essentially if you were you know if you
were traveling on a boat for months at a
time you you needed food that wasn't
going to spoil one might think like oh
why don't they just fish over the side
of the boat there's not that many fish
just like swimming around in the middle
of the Atlantic Ocean
most fish kind of hug shorelines and
continental shelves so like that's not
incredibly viable so mostly what they
would eat is just hardtack which was
basically like really hard dry bread not
much moisture so not much like mold or
rot could could take place and heavily
heavily salted meat the salt would also
kill bacteria and it preserved it really
well so you know like salted pork salted
beef salted fish all of those things
interestingly are don't have a ton of
vitamin C and so the British you might
remember this guy's name I'm blanking on
his name arguably the first randomized
control trial ever I remember the story
but not gonna hang it yeah so I'm
blanking on the dude's name but he was a
hero performed what very well may have
been the first randomized control trial
that ever occurred basically you saw
like hey all of our sailors are getting
scurvy and that's not good maybe they're
missing something in their food because
their diet is incredible
when their own ships so let's just try
to give them a bunch of stuff like
various things one at a time and see if
any of these various substances prevent
scurvy and so one of the things they
tested was lime juice and lime juice has
a lot of vitamin C they didn't know that
at the time they didn't know lack of
vitamin C called scurvy but they did
find if our sailors drink a little bit
of lime juice every day they don't get
scurvy anymore and so if you've ever
heard of like the British Navy being
referred to as limeys that's why people
found out they drank lime juice and
they're like that's weird those weird
British people [ __ ] limeys
but that plate of pretty large role in
the British Empire becoming like the
dominant Imperial force during that era
because basically like they could sail
different places take their army and
arrive reasonably healthy to get on with
like the conquest and rape and pillaging
whereas like if the French or the
Spanish did it by the time they landed
they'd be in some rough shape
yeah I mean the scurvy is a it's a
disaster I mean you're breaking down
collagen yeah and you're unable to
replace it due to this lack of vitamin C
so it's it's a horrible horrible yeah
don't you die from internal bleeding
yeah yeah yeah so basic your structures
loose structure yeah you have collagen
in the walls of your blood vessels and
as that breaks down and you're unable to
replace that collagen your blood vessels
get weaker and weaker and weaker one of
the early signs of scurvy well one of
them is you start bleeding from your
gums just because like your I guess your
teeth get loose and your gums are
reasonably thin in the first place like
those walls break down you bleed from
your gums
you'll also show like basically speckled
skin like petechiae because like
capillaries rupture and you just have
like tiny little bruises all over your
body and then few weeks later you're
dead because more major blood vessels
mess
so anyway vitamin C very important for
the British Empire back in the day very
important for collagen synthesis now
yeah there was a show recently called
the terror the first season of it they
were on a naval expedition and this was
a key thing with scurvy played a big
role in the show and they were always
like how much lime juice do we have left
in life is it still good and stuff like
that was actually it was a really
fascinating show it I mean it was
totally like fictitious yeah historical
fiction but yeah in any case this played
a a big role now the the dosing usually
gelatin or collagen in these types of
studies you're gonna dose somewhere
around 5 to 15 grams per day usually 10
to 15 that's usually going to be
combined with about 50 milligrams of
vitamin C and if you're worried about
you know vitamin C I heard that stops my
muscle growth we've got an article
coming out soon about that but rest
assured 50 milligrams is nowhere near a
dose to be worried about that
we also discussed it I think on the last
podcast before I break right to some
extent yeah I can't remember how far
into detail we went okay so I am a
little bit curious with these studies so
if you have a diet that's already high
in vitamin C and you're getting high
protein intake from diverse protein
sources particularly those with with
glycine which actually can be kind of
hard to find depending on your protein
sources I'd be curious to see exactly
how much of these potential benefits
basically just wash away in the absence
of that type of diet but in any case it
does seem to be a nice strategy to kind
of hedge your bets and make sure you've
got enough of those materials around for
collagen synthesis the one thing to keep
in mind high doses of hydroxyproline
which will be in those collagen and
gelatin supplements it's something you'd
want to keep an eye out for the
potential formation of kidney stones
these trials have been pretty long and
haven't had like you know haven't
reported panicked like oh like a third
of our sample got kidney stones or
anything like that but it theoretically
it's something that you would want to
keep an eye out for now the question
also asked a little bit about skin I'm
gonna share
my bias here I just don't care that much
about skin so this is not an area I've
looked into a lot I'll probably change
my tune as I get older and then skin
changes start becoming more relevant to
me but in any case I totally understand
why someone else would have an interest
in it but for me I'm young and
indestructible and I'm gonna live
forever so what do I care about skin
aging hell yeah
okay so there is a there's actually
several reviews out there in the
literature not the type of literature
I'm usually in it's a lot of like
cosmetically oriented journals not like
sports science ones but there's one by a
recent one by Choi at all in 2019 and I
mean to sum it all up the research
that's available for collagen
supplements and skin it's pretty good
there's emerging of evidence suggesting
like this stuff we have already would
suggest that it's pretty good for wound
healing and skin aging there have been a
number of studies looking at all oral
collagen supplements which have
favorable effects on skin elasticity
hydration and dermal collagen density so
the collagen research when it comes to
skin related outcomes does seem to be
pretty pretty favorable so overall it
does look like there's some good stuff
out there for skin applications in
addition to bone and connective tissues
the bone and connective tissue stuff is
a little bit more preliminary it looks
like the body of skin related literature
is larger based on what I saw in that
review the big caveat is don't expect
much in terms of effects on muscle when
it comes to collagen and gelatin
supplementation there's a paper by stu
phillips in 2017 that had a bunch of
protein quality scores and collagen was
0 which is not a high score so so it
doesn't have an amino acid mixture
that's gonna be particularly favorable
at all for general muscle growth but as
a special you know a very specific
supplement oriented toward those
connective tissues and potentially skin
as well there is some some favorable
research out there ok any comments on on
your skin routine Craig no not really
you want to keep that one close to the
chest you know
yeah keep your friends close keep your
skincare routine closer exactly okay
this next question is for Greg is from
salqeen NIF trip that's how I'm gonna
pronounce it sure even higher percentage
likelihood that I mispronounced that one
so it's not a stronger by science
podcast episode with at least without at
least one or two butchered names
no I new year very same us for sure okay
so the question is what do you think
about Brian minors theory on progress
being able to lift more being a result
of hypertrophy rather than hypertrophy
being a result of lifting heavier so so
that's a good question
like Brian miner he's a good guy
I do too not to be mistaken with Fort
Minor I think that's a common point of
confusion but both very very cool so
Brian wrote an article back in I believe
January 2018 called is load progression
necessary for hypertrophy on the website
my oh Journal and I assume that that is
the the source of this theory that Sal
Kim is asking about and so essentially
Brian argues that that essentially like
progressive overload people think about
it backwards it's less that training
harder going up in weight doing more
reps etc is what causes progress and
more so that being able to go heavier do
more reps etc is reflective of the fact
that progress has occurred and so like
basically I agree with that and I think
that it kind of just depends we're in
the chicken and egg scenario of
progressive overload and muscle growth
you're talking about so essentially how
this goes down is you know if you're
untrained you need an adequate stimulus
to get bigger and stronger and that
doesn't have to be a particularly huge
stimulus like you're not doing anything
you do something adaptations occur so
then you get bigger and stronger and
then you need a larger absolute stimulus
in order to maintain a sufficient
relative stimulus to get bigger and
stronger yet didn't you do that and you
get bigger and stronger and then you
need a larger absolute stimulus to
continue getting bigger and stronger if
you're keeping effort pretty similar the
whole time as you are getting bigger and
stronger loads drift up and so you can
you if you you could come away with the
idea of you know going up in weight and
volume helps you get bigger and stronger
or you can come away with the idea of
you get bigger and stronger and that
helps you go up in volume and weight
both of those things are kind of true
depending what part of that cycle you're
looking at what I will say just in
general is I think that I think that
people have a lot of incorrect ideas
about progressive overload or at least
at minimum a lot of people have a lot of
different ideas about progressive
overload to the point that I don't even
know that I like the term anymore
because I think that it causes more
confusion than it helps actually clarify
the concept you're talking about
so not everyone but when a lot of people
talk about progressive overload the only
thing that comes to mind is just oh you
need to do progressive overload so just
add more weight on the bar every session
or every week or every month or whatever
it could also include like you know
doing more reps adding sets or whatever
making training more challenging but
like the original definition of
progressive overload is basically that
very simplistic version of yeah just
every session as you're able add more
weight to the bar
that's essentially what the term meant
when Delorme coined it back in like the
late 40s when he was doing research on
untrained soldiers during the World War
era and so for the population he was
working with like that is a perfectly
valid definition and perfectly it's a
comprehensive enough way of looking at
it for untrained lifters adaptations do
take place quite quickly and so you know
in order to maintain a large enough
stimulus to keep them challenged and
keep them improving you do basically
need to go up and wait
virtually every training session or at
least every week so that was like the
context in which the coin was termed but
I don't know that it's all that helpful
of a concept when you're talking about
more well trained lifters so essentially
if you're looking at progressive
overload that way then you know you're
an intermediate lifter you're an
advanced lifter progress is either
slowed down or like you've hit a plateau
and if you take the view of progressive
overload meaning just going up in weight
or volume like causes continued
adaptation and that's the thing driving
everything you could very easily work
yourself kind of into a hole where like
maybe your training has gotten pretty
challenging you're having issues
recovering from it and then if you're
like well the way I get things moving
again is progressive overload and
progressive overload means adding more
weight or doing more volume that could
could very easily tip yourself over into
overreaching or overtraining if that's
like the concept you're working with
whereas if you take perspective more
similar to Bryan's and it's it's less
that going up in weight and volume
causes growth and more that growth and
an improved performance is permissive of
increases in weight and volume then
you're you're not going to run into that
same issue and it I think is a more
useful way of conceptualizing things
because essentially you're you're
focused on progress and your performance
which is like Act what you want to to to
be focused on like you want to get
bigger you want to get stronger
other than focusing on a proxy like if
you're focused just on progressive
overload you're focused on the proxy of
how much weight is on the bar and how
much volume am i doing and so you might
have a tendency to optimize your
training for the proxy the proxy being
how much weight a my lifting how much
volume am I doing and trying to improve
that rather than staying focused on and
is that actually getting me the results
I won't so personally I like I said I'm
not crazy about the term progressive
overload just because I think it does
cause a lot of confusions because some
people have kind of a nuanced view of it
and some people have a more simplistic
view of it I kind of like to term things
so this this is something I've been
meaning to write an article about like
for years and just haven't gotten around
to it but instead of the term
progressive overload I like to term
things either a sub adaptive stimulus
and adaptive stimulus or a maladaptive
stimulus and so essentially the name of
the game with any coaching is to make
sure that the stimulus is appropriate
you want it to be a large enough
stimulus and a stimulus of the correct
sort do calls adaptations and
specifically the type of adaptations you
want you don't want this stimulus to be
too small to cause adaptations and you
don't want the stimulus to be so large
that people can't beneficially adapt to
it and so if you think about things in
that way it will necessarily accomplish
what progressive overload does of you
know as you get bigger and stronger you
need to train harder in an absolute
sense like going up in volume or going
up in weight to keep the stimulus large
enough to cause more adaptations like
for it to continue to be an adaptive
stimulus if you didn't do progressive
overload as your capacity improved
eventually what is now an adaptive
stimulus would become a sub adaptive
stimulus but it keeps you from just
focusing on going up and load and going
up in volume for its own sake and
potentially risking your training
becoming large enough to be a
maladaptive stimulus
and so like that's personally how how I
look at it and I think I think that made
sense and it will make more sense when I
have time to actually like sit down and
write an article about it and like
really flesh this out but yeah
essentially I think I agree with Brian's
perspective and and how he personally
looks at this I do think it's a chicken
and egg scenario where are you looking
at the part of the cycle where you do
have to increase stimulus to cause more
adaptation are you looking at the part
of the cycle where adaptation has
occurred and therefore you can go up in
weight and volume and I think that
focusing on the latter part of that
cycle is generally a more productive way
to go about it and and avoid some of the
pitfalls of just you know maximizing
load and volume for their own sake and
focusing on proxies instead of outcomes
and one thing I'll note and I need to be
careful of how I word this because I'm
afraid it'll come across as salty and I
don't anticipate it to come across as
salty I'm more so like trying to back up
this concept so the question asks like
what do I think about Brian minors
theory and so that makes it sound like
this is an idea that one person has and
maybe since there is a person espousing
it it's kind of a fringe minority view
so with that pretext like he wrote this
article in 2018 I'm sure he had that
idea floating around in his head before
that I posted about this on Facebook and
read it back in like 2016 like literally
this exact same concept I had the idea
from like reading some of mike to sheer
stuff because it seems to be a pretty
clear implication of using like auto
regulation and rpe to progress load
essentially as you get stronger and as
your physical capacities improve if you
keep our Pease the same load just kind
of naturally progresses like it's the
same concept
Mike tee chimed in on Facebook and said
like yeah this is how I
get it to in like I'm sure that we
aren't the only three people who have
had this concept so if you go back and
read like really really old school
accounts of the training process like
you know people like arthur Saxon and
Doug Hepburn this kind of I this way of
looking at it is kind of inherent to how
they approach training as well I kind of
think I mean I kind of think this is how
most good coaches look at it essentially
you're taught a very simplistic and
stripped-down
and maybe not all that helpful version
of progressive overload in like an
undergrad exercise physiology class and
then as you coach more and get more
experience you do develop a more nuanced
idea of it and I think it kind of
converges upon the ideas that Brian put
forth in that article I've talked to
Eric Helms about this as well I think he
views progressive overload pretty much
the same as well
so anyway I'm not I'm not trying to say
that Brian like stole my thunder or
anything like that because I know with a
million percent certainty that I wasn't
the person that came up with the idea
either
I just want to make it clear that it's
not like you know Brian is a lone
prophet in the wilderness and is the
only person who has this concept it's
not like a it's not like a minority
thing that's kind of like fringe and you
should thus be super skeptical of I
think it's a very reasonable way of
conceptualizing progress that most
coaches kind of converge on over time
anyways so yeah I'm a supporter of it
and I think it's a good way to think
about progress more so than just like
the super simplistic version of
progressive overload that maybe you
learned in undergrad very good all right
that's a nice Q&A segment we're gonna
move on now to a research roundup
segment and you know we committed to
making sure that this show wasn't going
to be five hours long
so I'm gonna try to be very concise and
brief with the research round up here
two studies I found recently that I
thought were pretty interesting they're
not necessarily related but I just
thought they were cool the first one is
called the effects of acute caffeine
theanine and tyrosine supplementation on
mental and physical performance in
athletes now last year I published an
article on the website stronger by
science calm about caffeine and in that
caffeine article I mentioned that
caffeine probably pairs pretty well with
theanine and tyrosine but there's not a
lot of research looking directly at that
specific combination certainly I didn't
come up with that as it's something
others have written about before but
unfortunately there's not a lot of
research specifically looking at all
three of them together so when I saw
this title of this article I was stoked
I was really really excited and just to
talk about the background a little bit
so tyrosine is an amino acid that's
found in a lot of different protein
sources and it's a precursor to l-dopa
so so the the kind of pathway here is
tyrosine to l-dopa to dopamine which is
a neurotransmitter and then some
dopamine is converted to nerve
norepinephrine as well the the general
effects we associate with tyrosine would
be related to energy alertness cognitive
function things like that now with
theanine and this is different from Thea
cream so that's a really important
distinction theanine is a non dietary
amino acid that's found in green tea and
black tea mostly and some other things
as well
and theanine has effects on the
GABAergic and glutamatergic
neurotransmitter pathways and the
effects we associate with this are more
related to relaxation but importantly
not sedation so you you get a relaxed
sense from this but you don't feel tired
or sleepy and so the idea is
theoretically tyrosine might potentiate
some of the favorable effects of
caffeine when it comes to especially
things like alertness and cognitive
function in acuity
then theanine might level out some of
the relatively negative things we
associate with caffeine I think a lot of
people who use caffeine regularly have
had those days where you take a little
too much and you feel anxious and
jittery and just generally not good why
are you smiling
have I incriminating both of us here no
I've heard that's a thing that that has
literally never happened to me oh that's
me all the time dude the more caffeine I
consume the better I feel up to some
limit that I haven't found yet that bet
is not my experience but anyways so I
saw this title and I was like yes
finally I was really excited but as
you're gonna see I'm a little bit
annoyed with the study I'm not gonna lie
so they looked at 20 current or former
or former male collegiate athletes with
with a mean age of twenty point five it
was a placebo controlled crossover trial
so every participant did the treatment
condition but also the placebo condition
and basically served as their own
control they completed a few different
assessments related to mental and
physical performance before and after
the provision of either the supplement
or the placebo as well as after two
rounds of exercise now going up to this
point I'm like awesome this is really
cool but there was one thing about the
study that really irked me I want to be
very clear there's there are researchers
on this paper that I have a tremendous
amount of respect for they do good work
I think this decision was most likely
taken out of their hands but somebody
made this decision which drives me crazy
they refused to disclose the dosage of
the supplement used and I think they
also neglected to provide an actual
specific supplement name and so like
when I read that I was like are you
kidding me like that's really
frustrating because can you imagine if
it was a study it's like hey we're
looking at the toxicity of Tylenol it
seems like it was fine you go oh oh sick
I mean how much did you give hey that's
we're not really willing to share that
unfortunately it was a proprietary
amount of Tylenol yeah like that's just
how could you even pretend that's
helpful to anybody yeah you know what I
mean like dosage matters what this stuff
and so I was reading the paper and I was
kind of annoyed because again I don't
think the researchers willingly made
that decision but somebody did which is
frustrating however this is one of the
beauties of of pre-registration they
pre-registered the trial and in the
trial registration they did have the
dosing information so according to the
pre-registration which should line up
with the paper it was 75 milligrams of
caffeine 75 milligrams of theanine and 2
grams of tyrosine
now the two grams of tyrosine I like
that I like the one-to-one ratio between
caffeine and theanine but that caffeine
dose is really low so unfortunately when
I saw that it really took the wind out
of my sails in terms of my enthusiasm
for this one another thing is that the
outcomes aren't super relevant for what
most people are most of our listeners
are interested in so they did the rounds
of exercise they did had nine exercises
and they they just did them for 45
seconds and did as many reps as they
could and the exercises were like battle
ropes other battle ropes another battle
ropes exercise kettlebell swings line
jumps toe touches mountain climbers BOSU
squats which I know Greg programs those
all the time hell yeah and burpees so
the performance outcomes really weren't
super again it was one of those things
where I I saw the title and had such
high hopes about it and like I said I
respect a lot of the researchers on this
paper so I'm not like trying to bash
them but this one just wasn't the paper
for me you know it I don't like the
dosing and I don't like the exercises
but in any case what they found was
improved movement accuracy with a
particular like reaction test or like
tasks that they were doing they didn't
find improvements in physical
performance or the subjective
assessments they did looking at energy
focused concentration alertness fatigue
and motivation but again with that
dosing I really wouldn't expect
whole lot specifically from the caffeine
so you know for me the perfect design
for this is using some traditional
resistance training type tests and you
have an ERG agenda dose of caffeine with
theanine and tyrosine sensibly dosed
versus a caffeine only condition that
would be fantastic
I expect that the effect would be very
small but but I still I mean every day
with with my first caffeine dose of the
day of which there are many
I do have theanine and tyrosine it's a
small effect it's mostly related to
cognitive sharpness and just general
alertness and wakefulness but in any
case I saw the title I was like Helia
and then I read and I was like an ass it
wasn't what I hoped so this is just my
like in equals one experience so take it
or leave it very well may not be
normative and you know I could just be
placebo in myself but my experience with
not so much theanine but tyrosine
specifically is that if I am well-rested
and I'm generally sleeping good and I
combine caffeine and tyrosine versus
just caffeine I can't tell a like a
difference but if I'm pretty worn down
and sleep deprived and I just use
caffeine or use caffeine and tyrosine
together I do notice a considerable
difference we're adding the tyrosine
into the mix does help me feel quite a
bit better you know maybe that's just
because like with sleep deprivation
dopamine levels go down maybe that's due
to neural [ __ ] or maybe it's just due to
lack of raw materials to continue making
dopamine because you don't really have
that much dopamine when you're asleep so
maybe that helps like replenish the raw
materials pool I don't know I don't know
how all of that works I just know that
my own experience with it is that
tyrosine does does seem to give me a
little more pep in my step when I'm
sleep-deprived but not so much when I'm
well-rested and like not being a
complete degenerate
yeah I haven't I don't have as close of
a personal relationship with sleep
deprivation as you do so I can't confirm
or deny that but but I do I like the
theanine with with caffeine because like
I said I am a little bit prone to some
of the jitteriness and the increased
anxiousness but in any case it's still
an interesting supplementation strategy
there's still evidence there but
unfortunately we know we need a lot more
of it and and ideally essentially with
the design I mentioned like I'd like to
see what they do above and beyond
caffeine when caffeine is dosed at a
higher higher dosage okay the next study
I saw I'm gonna be very brief about this
one is a long title it was called high
compared with moderate protein intake
reduces adaptive thermogenesis and
induces a negative energy balance during
long-term weight loss maintenance in
participants with pre-diabetes in the
post obese state a preview study and so
what they were looking at here they had
38 participants they did they did a
weight loss diet and this was looking at
them 34 months after the weight loss and
they had them on these two different
diets and looked at their they had him
in a respiration chamber for 48 hours
looking at a variety of different
metabolic outcomes the two diets one was
high-protein one was moderate protein so
the high protein diet was 25% protein by
calories or 25% of calories from protein
and then 30% from fat and the rest from
carbohydrate the moderate protein group
was 15% protein 30% fat and again the
rest from carbohydrate so the results
the higher protein diet when they were
in the respiration chamber had lower
energy balance and higher resting energy
expenditure and so for that group the
resting energy expenditure was not
different from their predicted resting
energy expenditure it was only about 48
calories lower than predicted in the
moderate protein group it was about 119
calories lower than
predicted so these findings obviously
it's not a huge difference but it's not
totally negligible and if you're
listening to this podcast you probably
already knew that you should be eating a
pretty high-protein diet whether you're
actively losing weight or if you're in
that post weight loss period but the
reason that this one kind of caught my
eye we did a study a while back I think
it was published in 2017 looking at a
group of fifteen physique athletes and
we're talking about competitive physique
athletes who all eat high-protein diets
I mean that's that's the rule rather
than the exception with physique
athletes and one of the things we found
it was a small sample but we did find
that the resting metabolic the changes
in resting metabolic rate that we
observed seem to correlate with the
protein intake that they were consuming
after the competition so basically the
recovery of resting metabolic rates seem
to be correlated with that protein
intake initially I didn't look too far
into it because I was like hey it's a
small sample correlations happen but
still interesting enough to report and
this is kind of the same type of thing
where I'm leaning more and more as I see
studies looking at different
macronutrient combinations in the post
weight loss period I'm leaning more and
more toward really prioritizing protein
and in some cases even increasing it
beyond what it was in the diet at least
in the short term I especially people
who are hoping to maintain some degree
of leanness so you know I'm not really
into the idea of after you compete
staying shredded for like the rest of
your life for as long as you can until
you crack I think that's a really bad
plan but so like an application of this
might be if you're someone who competes
in a physique show and maybe you have
another one in six weeks I don't know if
I've ever heard anyone talk about this
or write about it but that's the worst
thing in the world
so when you are at least from my
experience prepping for shows is easy
but when you are just trying to stay in
the best shape of your life and not
actually get better or worse for six
weeks it's so hard to motivate yourself
to stay in that kind of shape
I mean it's brutal so some people take
that approach where they're like oh well
we'll like reverse out of it and hit a
show on the tail end or something like
that like increase calories maybe we
show up a little bit fuller but I think
one of the benefits of that approach is
just giving your mind something to focus
on so like oh hey look we're doing this
this new reverse diet thing it's a thing
we're doing now rather than just like
getting in shape and saying okay do the
same thing for the next six weeks and
try not to hate it because you're gonna
hate it in my experience but I do think
there's something interesting about it
and I mean the the mechanisms that the
authors put forward are kind of the
standard ones you see so maybe it's the
increased satiety maybe it's the
increased thermic of feeding maybe some
combination within those but it does
seem to have some particular utility
when it comes to the maintenance of
weight loss maybe particularly
particularly if it's like a short
stretch of time where you're a physique
athlete and you're really trying to hold
on to it maybe you do a competition and
you've got a photo shoot four weeks
after or something like that I do think
there's something to this strategy I
don't expect that it's gonna be a
complete game changer and obviously you
know you're you're gonna be eating high
protein anyway if you're on a good
weight loss diet and really getting
shredded but you know even for like
general population people who are like
okay I'm out of this weight loss phase
does that mean that my protein needs are
kind of back to normal
I would say the evidence would indicate
is probably not a bad idea to keep them
high and you might even play around with
a theoretical strategy of increasing
them to try to successfully complement
this this weight maintenance so when
would protein and take come back down
after that whoo that's a good question
the way I see it maybe it's something
that you lean on in this initial initial
stage and kind of taper it down from
there so like you know that when it
comes to weight maintenance from a
pretty serious weight loss attempt it's
usually that initial window where you
really want to manage it and
successfully transition into maintenance
mode and again so this we're talking
general population here if you have some
idea that you're gonna get shredded for
a competition and stay that way forever
I think that's
idea period but for that type of person
who's trying to actually maintain this
weight loss for a long time maybe you
use it as a crutch to kind of
successfully transition into that
maintenance period you leave the protein
kind of elevated beyond what it really
needs to be for I don't know a month or
two and start tapering it down from
there once they've realized like okay
I've got my feet underneath me this has
been a successful transition we're
maintaining and think like we've said
many times before on the show the things
that really seem to correlate with good
weight loss maintenance are continuing
to track body weight continuing to track
your intake and then also keeping your
physical activity level high so I could
see this as being like those three
things are key like they have to be
there in this initial transition phase I
would see this as like a fourth like I
said just a little bit of a boost to
give you a step in the right direction
I don't expect it's a huge effect I mean
we talked about the calorie numbers
there that's nothing special but but if
every little bit counts in this
particular it's kind of a fragile time
window where it's like okay are we going
to successfully make this transition or
not and I can see it fitting in that
particular time window and then if
you're like okay I'd like to shift to
slightly more enjoyable macronutrient
split and then you start tapering down
again this is totally theoretical based
on you know two studies one of which was
extremely small but but I do think it's
we don't have that many tools for this
type of thing right like so metabolic
adaptation everybody's like how do you
solve it there's not a whole lot that we
can really do with it so if we find
something like this that can facilitate
that transition phase in this adaptive
kind of post diet state it's probably a
good thing make sense to me okay has
anyone considered pulling their
metabolism back up by its own bootstraps
that's a good question I think a lot of
people just don't have the the fortitude
to do that the toughness and the the
folks just aren't willing to take
personal responsibility for it correct
that's a joke we're joking
all right Greg do I think you have a
coach's corner planned for us don't you
I do yeah so new year is upon us
this is around the time when a lot of
people might consider starting to cut
either for spring break or summer fun
fact if you look at temp temporal
changes in weight over time generally
most people do a pretty good job
maintaining weight from like mid January
to November this is in the u.s. with the
way our holiday season works but then
basically they gain several pounds
during the Thanksgiving Christmas season
and then just maintain weight moving
forward and don't lose that weight so
you know basically it's a new year's
time a lot of people are trying to lose
weight a lot more people should probably
be trying to lose weight so if if that
applies to you let's talk about training
and some strategies you can use to you
know make training on a deficit slightly
less unpleasant because the thing is you
know if you've been training for a while
you know that training at maintenance
and certainly in a surplus is a lot more
fun than training and a deficit it's fun
to get stronger and your performance
improve if you're like a beginner or
early intermediate lifter like you can
almost certainly continue to improve
performance and a deficit but at a
slightly slower rate but it's it's just
less fun all around and I know that that
has like foiled prior weight loss
attempts for me if I'm being completely
honest because I'm a power lifter and
focused on performance if performance
starts dropping that is psychologically
tough for me just because like I like
lifting heavy [ __ ] and I don't
particularly want to start lifting
lighter [ __ ] you know so anyway here are
some strategies that one could use to
maybe make this period
at least a little bit easier
psychologically because ultimately with
a cut if you're you're trying to
possibly increase but realistically just
maintain the amount of muscle you have
and for that as long as you keep
training things are probably gonna be
pretty fine all of the research we have
looking at people who are training in a
deficit basically finds it until people
are getting like super super lean
they're able to maintain muscle mass
just fine
so I mean realistically as long as
you're still getting in the gym and
training hard things will be okay and so
really you need to be more focused on
like how can you train in a manner that
you won't lose your motivation you know
if if performance starts dropping and so
here here are just a couple simple
things you can do one is just do more
bodyweight stuff as like core lifts in
your program so you know if you're
mostly focused on squat bench deadlift
when you're cutting maybe you could put
a little bit more focus on exercises
like dips and pull-ups simply because
like one if you don't put a lot of focus
on them in your program generally you're
probably gonna be able to make some
gains fairly quickly just as you get
better at the movements and get used to
them and then - as weight comes off the
scale you now weigh less and it's easier
to get your body weight above the bar or
to do dips with your bodyweight and so
that can be the you're kind of the cut
is working towards you rather than
against you it's less like you have you
know less mass to control and handle
heavy weight and more like now you have
less mass that you're trying to move
through space so a larger focus on
bodyweight stuff and specifically
thinking pull-ups and dips here for
people who are stronger maybe like
inverted rows and push-ups for people
who aren't quite as strong that can that
can be a good strategy and then
something else you can do and this is
what I have done previously to maintain
motivation for longer during a cut
is basically to include more variation
in like the core lifts of your program
and so you know basically if your
training program revolves around squat
bench deadlift and you're doing them
weekend week out all the time and you're
already quite strong and quite skilled
maybe when you start cutting the first
couple months go fine and then you start
losing a little bit of strength and
that's the motivating something you can
do to work around that if you're not
someone who just psychologically has to
squat bench deadlift every week is you
can just do something like three week
waves with clothes variations of the
main lifts so for example instead of
benching for three weeks you could do
Close Grip or you could do like a low
incline press or you could do Spoto
press or any other number of clothes
variations of the bench press same thing
for the squat if you traditionally squat
blow bar with a belt you could maybe do
three weeks of beltless squats or three
weeks of high bar squats or three weeks
of Paul squats or three weeks of front
squats a lot of different options you
could go for if there are things you
don't use super often in your training
same sort of thing could take place as
as will occur with pull-ups and dips for
those three weeks
your performance probably improves week
to week to week just as you build skill
with exercises that you do a little bit
less frequently then you know when you
actually start getting quite good at
them it might be about to hit a wall you
sub them back in for something else you
as long as they're close variations you
should still have enough motor skill
that you can put sufficient stimulus on
the muscles to maintain muscle mass so
that shouldn't necessarily be a problem
but you're essentially just in a process
of week to week to week performances
going up and that feels good
your actual performance like if you did
a one rep max squat it may still be
where it was before maybe slightly
depressed but like your week to week
experiences performance is going up and
that feels good if you're worried about
getting rusty with your main lifts you
can just include them as things that you
cycle in so
you know maybe for bench you do three
weeks of Close Grip you do three weeks
of low incline then you do three weeks
of comp style bench and then you do
three weeks of bench with chains and
then you do three weeks of Spoto press
and then you do three weeks of calm
style bench you just you know include
that as something that's like every
third variation just to make sure you
stay you know somewhat in practice or
you could just do it as part of your
warmup where when you're warming up for
any other bench variation and by the way
this would apply to squat and deadlift
as well you know you just work up to a
single or like eighty eighty-five
percent on the core lifts battle that
will keep the motor pattern reasonably
fresh should help it keep from getting
rusty I don't think you need to do that
but if that's something that you think
would stress you out you can keep the
main lifts in your program in some way
shape or form instead of you know
completely neglecting them for several
months at a time and then I also think
this can make things more fun at the end
of a cut as well because especially if
your core loves to get a little rusty
they might be like artificially
depressed a bit at the end of your cut
and so then when you transition back
into maintenance or a slight surplus you
get pretty rapid strength gains on the
core lifts you care about the most just
as you get back in practice and that's
fun as well
so basically like different people are
wired differently I think that I don't
know I think that like more hypertrophy
focused people care less about
performance and as long as their
physique looks good and maybe they can
still get a pump it matters a little bit
less if performance is going down in the
gym but for strength athletes
performance going down on a cut just can
be super demotivating so using some of
these strategies you should like be able
to improve absolute performance and body
weight exercises like you know say
number of reps you can do with body
weight just as your body weight goes
down that's working in your favor and
bicycling in more lifts your week to
week day to day performance is that Oh
like my performance is improving I can
do more reps I can do more weight week
to week to week
and that's fun that feels good and you
should still be able to keep inducing an
adequate stimulus to maintain your
muscle and so ultimately it's
accomplishing what you want it to so
yeah you don't have to do that but those
those are some things I would generally
recommend especially if you've tried to
cut before and you found yourself
aborting it because you know you did
lose motivation as a performance started
taking a hit you can use some of these
strategies it may make the process a
little bit psychologically easier for
you I really like that those are some
good tips I think a lot of people just
kind of they reserved themselves to the
idea like well I'm gonna cut this is
gonna suck I don't think a lot of people
think about proactive strategies of like
how do we manage that that that's really
nice I like those tips so to play us out
we've got two things the first one's
from me the second from Greg I'm gonna
be brief with mine so mine's a little
we're gonna grab a piece of feedback out
of the mailbag here so somebody messaged
Greg with this do you remember who sent
this well I don't know if they want
their name shared though because my Q&A
it's implied but I don't remember it yes
anyway you know who you are
and we appreciate it but basically we
talked to several episodes back about a
big meta-analysis where they looked at
recommendations pertaining to the intake
of red meat and processed meat and their
general conclusion was like you can kind
of just keep doing what you're doing
right and it caused a bit of a stir
because red meat and processed meat tend
to be very much vilified in the
nutrition world so a lot of people were
annoyed by the conclusions of the paper
as we talked about in our segment if you
look deeper into the paper really what
they said was like my interpretation of
their work was like yeah it's probably a
good idea to keep your your intake of
processed meats and fatty red meats you
know within the low to moderate range
but realistically people kind of hate
doing it and if that's the only diet
change you're making it's probably not
going to completely revolutionize your
health so like I think a lot of people
saw the
headlines and thought wow these guys
just took a really irresponsible shot at
everything we know about nutrition and I
really don't think their paper
lived up to that hype in a good way
actually this is a case where you don't
want to live up to that hype but in any
case so someone sent us an article about
the journal recently issued a correction
in the original paper there was a big
long list of conflicts of interest and
we noted in the show it even went so far
as like how often to eat red meat and
stuff like that but the it was it was a
thorough conflict of interest reporting
section correct yeah which I believe is
kind of part of this grade approach that
they took but in any case the journal
issued a correction that the lead author
failed to disclose I think it was one a
funding source that they should have
disclosed I think it was one maybe two
it was one yeah what one of them was
like from before the period that they
were supposed to report they had like a
36 month period yeah but in any case so
there have been some articles saying
like well the whole paper is you know
you got to completely ignore it and
throw it out because of this and so the
person that sent us a question was
basically like what's your take on this
and personally I'm not I'm not that my
opinion on the conclusions of the paper
hasn't really changed much you know the
the original paper itself like I said it
was mostly just saying like hey all
these governing bodies have put out
these recommendations we believe that
they kind of lacked procedural rigor in
terms of establishing those guidelines
they might be overstating the magnitude
of the effect if we view these dietary
changes in a vacuum like in isolation
and these previous guidelines have
failed to consider basically how much
people are gonna hate implementing this
change if they're already a consumer of
these products so it wasn't quite as
strong a conclusion as people have kind
of made it out to be but one of the
reasons I'm not super concerned about
like oh we found this other conflict of
interest that wasn't reported so it's
important to
recognize that this was a systematic
review that was pre-registered okay so
what that means two things first of all
the methods were registered ahead of
time and second of all given that it's a
systematic review and meta-analysis the
data aren't coming from folders in their
lab right like these data are publicly
available published data the reason
that's important is because you can't if
it were a completely original research
study that wasn't pre registered you
could think like oh you know this person
because of their conflicts was probably
selectively reporting outcomes not
reporting the stuff that didn't fit
their narrative maybe some special
outliers got thrown out to make the
picture a little clearer for them you
could you could have concerns about some
of these things but the fact that it's a
meta-analysis means they're the analysis
has to be perfectly capable of being
replicated you know we all have access
to all of the data you know everyone
listening to this so you can't really be
super concerned that they did something
weird fudging numbers because it can all
be replicated and the fact that they pre
registered it if there was a bias which
I as I'm going to cover in a minute I
don't think they're I think it's pretty
unlikely but if there was basically the
biggest biggest ramification it could
have on this type of of research and
ever would be that before they started
it they basically stacked to the deck
and took an approach that they thought
would favor a particular finding I'm
really not that concerned about this
conflict of interest in that context
another thing is that the the funding
that was not disclosed which has now
been corrected to disclose the this was
the part that that floored me that they
made such a big deal about this yeah so
it was funded and this is my
understanding of just looking at a few
articles on it if I'm off-base here
please do reach out let us know if we're
miss characterizing the scenario in any
way but this is a snarky joke like most
people that report on health science
articles I haven't done a significant
amount of digging
it's just insane but anyway that's a
different thing so it was the Texas A&M
AgriLife Research that was this funding
mechanism that he had to report and so
the idea is that this AgriLife Research
thing is affiliated with Texas A&M
University it's like a university
directed program that receives partial
funding from the beef industry so
they're like the narrative if you want
to take a really alarmist interpretation
is this author's totally in the pocket
of the big beef industry but if you go
to the website for this Texas A&M
AgriLife Research if you go there web
page you see pictures of like fruits and
vegetables and cotton fields and wheat
and corn like it does seem to be like a
pretty general big fund for agricultural
agriculture related research it's not
like you go to the homepage and it's
just like nine kinds of steaks and it's
just pure beef I mean so of course
they're gonna receive funding from beef
they're gonna receive funding which
honestly seems slightly off-brand for
Texas A&M I know I I think it's either
Texas A&M or Texas Tech has like a
highly ranked meat tasting Club what
yeah we're like it's competitive meat
tasting where they like taste beef and
like III don't really understand how it
works someone from Texas told me about
it I wasn't Jake yes now I see why he's
trying to get back there exactly yeah
so in any case like it doesn't look
nearly as bad as some of the initial gut
reactions would be me it's possible like
I don't know the ins and outs of this
funding thing maybe there was like a sub
grant from this funding mechanism that
was specifically like sponsored by the
beef industry in which case yeah you
probably ought to report that but in any
case like the idea that this guy is like
paying his home mortgage based on his
affiliations with beef it's just it's
just off-base and here's something I
found that's funny if you wanted to be
like this this guy this the the lead
author his name is Johnston this idea
that
he's just out there as a mercenary for
the food industry promoting fat and
sugar because they may did talk in the
article about his sugar work as well
being like too complimentary to sugar or
too linked to sugar backed funding
sources so this is a paper where he was
the senior author like senior author has
sway on a paper he was the last author
listed it's called the influence of
unhealthy food and beverage marketing on
children's dietary intake and preference
a systematic review and meta-analysis of
randomized trials it was in 2016 he was
again the senior author and these are
two quotes from the paper marketing of
foods and beverages high in fat sugar
and salt are suggested to contribute to
poor dietary behaviors and children and
diet related diseases later in life
another quote from the paper unhealthy
food and beverage marketing increased
dietary intake and influence dietary
preference and children during or
shortly after exposure to advertisements
this does not sound like somebody who's
willing to sell his soul for the big
food industry I mean it was like right
off the bat that sugar salt disease bad
marketing shame on you like I just don't
see this being a particularly compelling
narrative that that this paper was like
shady I mean maybe that was when he was
in the pocket of big anti marketing
maybe yeah so that's my take on it I
really do think this is the type of
thing I mean these new like people in
this area of research they get grants
all over the place because that's how it
works like they're just getting grant
after grant after grant we're asking him
to kind of know exactly how much beef
money goes into this agriculture fund
from which he got a grant I just think
it's a whole bunch of a whole bunch of
noise not really that compelling yeah
one of the things you said which I
thought was rather apt when we were
discussing this few days ago was yeah
the the people who actually gave the
grant was the Texas Tech AgriLife
Research people you know that is a a
grant agency associated with a
university
giving out money that would be like in
and this is the example you gave like
UNC gets a lot of funding from like Big
Pharma and so it would be like getting a
departmental grant to study like I don't
know whatever the [ __ ] it is doesn't
really matter
and then people saying like well you and
see gets a lot of money from
GlaxoSmithKline therefore like you you
were necessarily promoting big pharma
right the added layer of it going
through the university before it goes
out to the researcher I think I think
makes a considerable difference here
yeah and like I said it's possible that
it was a specific sub grant that was
beef focused or something like that but
but that still is passing through an
entity that apparently is on the up and
up and it directly associated by name
with the university yeah yeah so I I
just don't see this as being nearly as
ominous as as it would look at first
glance and I would say honestly the most
important thing is it's a pre registered
meta analysis like I don't know where
you think the thumb is on the scale
that's skewing this thing anyway I mean
it's pretty transparent yeah I mean you
know if you want to say something about
it like see if you think the inclusion
criteria for studies was was 2 lakhs or
whatnot like if this is an area of
research you specialize in and you know
that like oh
looking at these inclusion criteria this
one inclusion or exclusion criteria is
somewhat sketchy if they wouldn't have
included that they would have included
these 5 other studies in this
meta-analysis that would paint a very
different overall picture like that
would be an incredibly legitimate
critique sure and I don't follow this
area of research closely enough to know
if that is a thing or not but that is
that is what you would want to critique
if you're critiquing a pre-registered
meta-analysis that are they [ __ ] their
stats up which like which like you said
you can pull up these papers extract the
data and recreate the meta so like if
that was the problem people who are
freaking out about the funding source
I'm sure they've already tried to do
that
like that's yeah that would be the first
place I'd go if I was trying to attack a
meta and second place that goes
inclusion criteria and so when when
people aren't actually critiquing the
science that was done and just jumped
straight to funding source especially
like you said in a meta-analysis not a
prospective study then it feels to me
like they're grasping at straws yeah and
there were some some criticisms like we
talked about the first time with this
paper where people said I think these
inclusion criteria weren't very good I
think this is me quoting these
hypothetical people people thought that
the inclusion criteria weren't great
people also thought that the great
approach that they took is not super
appropriate for this type of literature
because it does basically say like if
you're not an RCT you're not that you're
it's low-quality evidence right and so
for this body of literature you knew
going into it yeah a lot of this stuff
is gonna be called low quality so those
are those are valid complaints but what
were the issues with inclusion criteria
if you remember well I mean so what
happened was everyone who sells a you
know a super plant-based book or the
people who wrote these guidelines that
he's saying are a little bit too it too
enthusiastic they all kind of went at it
and said like well will this inclusion
criteria exclusion criteria prevented
you from including this paper which we
think is a really good paper it was that
kind of stuff so that's one of the
reasons why when it wasn't systematic
critique it was more just you didn't
include one or two papers that I
personally liked I mean there were
people who were like oh this thing is it
mat is a mess it's a disaster and it's
the people who really like advocating
for you know I mean there's this stuff
we see with all sorts of papers right
like there's two camps and they're gonna
go through and say all the inclusion
exclusion criteria are terrible but it's
it's people who are very transparently
biased accusing other people of bias
correct but I mean the thing is I this
is not an area of literature I cared
that much about which is why I didn't
like
Ivan and say oh no here's what the
criteria should be or shouldn't be like
my take on it which again remains
unchanged it's like he has I mean it's a
safe bet to like keep your processed and
fatty red meat intake within like low to
moderate ranges this paper acknowledge
that most people don't want to do that
which seems like like a safe bet so like
yeah I think it's generally advisable
but I mean if that's the only if you
have a generally trash diet and your
main thing that you do is I went from a
very highly processed meat to a slightly
less processed meat with similar
macronutrient composition like that's
probably not gonna affect your long-term
health outcomes that much like the I
just I think the main premise of the
paper is like yeah it's probably a good
idea but most people don't want to do it
if you do it they even mentioned in the
paper like yeah there's probably some
potential upside there which i think is
true yeah like if you if your main goal
is to live as long as humanly possible
with the longest health span yeah don't
eat a ton of fatty red meat and I'd say
limit your your processed meat and take
as much as much as you're willing to do
yeah like and I don't think this paper
really changed that much so that's one
of the reasons like my take on the paper
was never like oh wow you know the
tables have turned now we should all be
eating a ton of processed meat that's
why it's like does this change your
interpretation in the paper nah like you
probably ought to like if you want to
have a really nice super healthy diet
like eat a bunch of plants enough
protein and you're gonna be good I agree
alright so uh but I do want to mention
we really appreciate the listeners
sending that question it wasn't
interesting a little series of articles
reading through and trying to figure out
what was going on there I still think
you know one of the things I said back
in the day this kind of brings it full
circle David Katz has a phrase he uses a
lot with nutrition which is like yeah we
don't have all the answers but his
phrase is like let's use what we know
mm-hmm and so I do think like if you're
gonna tell me hey Eric I'm gonna replace
a lot of my processed meat intake with
fibrous vegetables that's a good move if
anyone tells you that's not a good move
that's insane
but the reason it comes full-circle his
cats very is very he advocates a lot of
plant-based diet stuff and was actually
one of the people interviewed in
game-changers so we are full circle all
right now Greg on a lighter note let's
talk some cooking tips to play us out
yes so last thing I talked about was how
to make it maybe slightly easier to cut
now let's talk about how to make it much
much harder to cut and that is I would
recommend that you make some homemade
caramel or caramel x' depending on how
you pronounce that so we did a holiday
gift exchange
I made some caramels or carton I I don't
know how to say that let's say
operationally define it well so I refer
to like if you're using it as an
ingredient in something else I say
caramel but then I call like the
individual candies caramels or caramels
I'm just gonna say caramel cuz that
rolls off the tongue better it does yes
anyway made some some caramels for a
holiday gift exchange a little dirty
Santa action they were very well
received and I must say they were
absolutely delicious chocolate very
passe
I think it's played out chocolates time
is over the age of chocolate is over the
age of caramel is upon us and it's not
that long until Valentine's Day so if
you want to impress your significant
other maybe make them some homemade
caramel that will you know get the
evening started off right maybe anyway
so here's how you make homemade caramel
x' and I'll also say like I love caramel
I prefer it to chocolate it's it's I
don't have a big sweet tooth but like
caramel
is definitely preferable to chocolate
for me like I love Twix growing up love
hundred grand bars like that's I think
caramels good stuff and this homemade
caramel is a trillion times better than
anything you would get like prepackaged
in the candy aisle so it's true I so I
had these and I don't know it almost
felt like the prepackaged stuff you get
had some kind of like structural agent
to give it body that headline used corn
starch as a binder that had like no
flavor to it whatsoever so it felt it
almost felt like the flavor is diluted
and the texture is far too hard in the
store-bought stuff this was a totally
different caramel experience yeah so
here's how you make caramels there will
be a video linked in the show notes this
is what I used as my guide it was from
America's Test Kitchen short video about
five minutes pretty easy to follow but
here's how you go about making caramel
you get two pots one of them is going to
have heavy cream and butter in it and
the other pot is going to have sugar
white corn syrup or any any type of high
glucose syrup so I think like tapioca
syrup would work as well
and possibly even like agave nectar but
one with sugar light corn syrup or some
sort of high glucose syrup and just a
little water to dissolve it all you're
gonna start by bringing the cream and
butter up to a light simmer and then
infusing with vanilla so I just used
like vanilla extract the video shows
like the person used like actual fresh
vanilla bean vanilla beans are [ __ ]
expensive it's like 20 bucks per vanilla
bean at least at the store I go to and
so like I'll do that for special
occasions I didn't necessarily want to
spend 20 bucks on a tray of caramel so I
just went with vanilla extract still
turned out well so you're gonna bring
that up to a simmer if you're using
extract you'll put the vanilla in at the
end
because you don't want all of that
flavor to evaporate and then basically
you just want to keep that mixture warm
so that it doesn't shock the syrup too
much when you add it in then in the
other pot with the sugar the high
glucose syrup and the water you're gonna
put that over like medium medium-high
heat and don't touch it to start with
let everything dissolve let all of the
water boil off you don't want to touch
it because if it gets all agitated the
sugars can recrystallize and then you
just have a mess so you want it all to
to be able to melt into like a
homogeneous liquid you'll Bowl you'll
boil all of the water off you want to
have a candy thermometer and on the
action so you can monitor temperature
because temperature control is crucial
for this recipe for a lot of things
temperature may not matter a ton but
when you're trying to make some sort of
sugar candy temperature temperature
control is the entire name of the game
so as it's coming up to temp it's gonna
pause at like - 210 212 Fahrenheit or
like a hundred Celsius for a while until
all of the water boils off once the
water is gone it will resume heating up
and you want to get it up to somewhere
in the neighborhood of 340 to 350
Fahrenheit which is 171 to 177 Celsius
and you can either do this by
temperature or by color for this first
part I'd actually recommend doing it by
color you want to have the thermometer
and to know when the temp is getting
close but basically if you let like the
sugar syrup will change from clear to
like kind of yellowish ambarish to kind
of more like deeper and darker red and
basically the further you go the the
more and more intense the flavor will
get and the more bitter it will get
that's one of the things I like about
homemade caramel like store-bought stuff
it's one note it's only sweet it's sweet
and kind of caramel II but it's one note
and it's boring when you make homemade
caramel it's going to have some bitter
notes from like the actually like burnt
and roasted sugar it gives a really nice
flavor contrast
and basically if you get it up to like
340 or 171 Celsius it's not going to
have much bitterness and it's going to
be a lighter color if you let it get
darker it's going to have a more intense
flavor a little more bitterness and like
a darker color you don't want to let it
get above 350 or 177 I believe sugar
starts burning at like 350 - or 178 so
like if you get up to 350 you're you you
have to watch it really really closely
because going from perfectly roasted
intense caramel to burnt sugar is a very
very fine line and as you get closer
like once you get up to like 330 I would
recommend 330 slash like 165 Celsius
I'd recommend turning the temperature
down to like low medium low so that like
the final 10 degrees Fahrenheit comes up
at a much slower rate so you have more
control over it so basically get that to
the to the color and temperature you
want it and then you want to add in the
cream and butter mixture back into the
very hot sugar syrup be incredibly
careful
so like the sugar syrup is 350 and it's
a liquid so it's gonna have a very very
high specific heat and transfer heat
incredibly well and so you want to just
add a little bit of the cream and butter
mixture at a time because it's going to
instantly like the watt a lot of the
water is going to instantly vaporize
into steam and that steam will be 350
degrees like water can only get up to
212 or 100 Celsius if you're near sea
level but steam can be [ __ ] hot like
it's it's steam all the way up to like
plasma temperature and 350 degrees steam
is not pleasant so you want to add just
a little bit of the cream and butter
mixture let it bubble let it steam then
stir it in then add a little bit more
and do it in like multiple editions and
you want to make sure that the sugar
mixture is in a big enough pot that as
it bubbles up it's not gonna run over
so anyway once you get that integrated
you want to put it back on the stove and
get it cooking again so now you have a
caramel sauce and to turn it into
caramels that you can then cut and eat
as a candy you need to get that mixture
of the the sugar and the cream and the
butter and the vanilla up to about 245
to 250 degrees Fahrenheit or about 118
to 121 Celsius closer to 245 and it's
going to have a softer texture closer to
250 and it's gonna be a little bit
harder if you just get it up to 245 you
may run into issues if you try to keep
them at room temperature they're still
gonna try to flow a little bit so you're
gonna need to keep that in the fridge
for sure
250 it should be a little bit safer at
room temperature but you know that's
just going to dictate the texture you're
working with but 245 to 250 will give
you the texture and the chew that you
would expect from a caramel candy and
then once you reach that you pull it off
the heat you pour it into a pan lined
with parchment paper and sprayed with
cooking spray so it doesn't stick too
bad let it cool a little bit at room
temp once it's getting close to room
temp pop it in the fridge after a couple
hours in the fridge it should be firmed
up and you can go ahead and cut it and
eat it might want to top it with sea
salt I'd highly recommend you do so and
I got to tell you treks just verified
this for you you can ask any of our
friends they're delicious they're so
good
it is dangerous of of the various things
one could do in the kitchen I would say
like deep frying things and really hot
oil is probably the most dangerous thing
I mean it's not like crazy dangerous but
like if you spill hot oil you're in a
world of hurt you get a grease fire
going you're [ __ ]
so you know that that's kind of it's
dangerous if you don't know what you're
doing
making caramels isn't like that but it
is you know it's more dangerous than
most things one would do in the kitchen
so you need to be careful with it but as
long as you watch out for that steam and
make sure you don't spill it you'll be
fine
and do not try the caramel until it's
cooled all the way down like it'll look
like once it stops steaming like once
all of the water is gone it'll look like
it's not that hot cuz you know if like
smoke or steam isn't rising off of stuff
you just automatically make the
connection of like oh this can't be that
hot but it's [ __ ] hot and like I said
it's a liquid it's gonna transfer heat
incredibly well it's easy to burn
yourself so just be careful if you do
this and you should be fine a couple
variations you can do with this is one
if you want to make caramel syrup
instead of making caramel candies you
follow the first part of the process
exactly the same you get milk and butter
you get vanilla you get the the sugar
syrup sugar and water you bring that up
to 340 350 get it to the level of
carmelization you want you add the the
cream and butter into the sugar but then
you just don't cook it after that you
get it well integrated you stir it up
well you let it cool you aren't driving
water off and you're not changing the
structure of it again by heating it back
up so it's going to have more water in
it it's gonna behave as a syrup and that
is a delightful ice cream topping that
was my first introduction to caramel
making actually made some some caramel
syrup for ice cream last year it is very
good so I'd strongly recommend trying
that as well if you like ice cream and
another thing you can do is during the
second cook like once you integrate the
butter and cream into the sugar and
you're bringing it up to temp you can
blow by the the to 45 to 50 that you
would to make caramel candies and get it
up to somewhere in the neighborhood of
270 to 300 Fahrenheit which is like 132
to 149 Celsius and you can basically
make like in like a caramel nougat or
hard candy like 270 would be more
nougaty like 270 / 132 would be more
nougat e300 / 149 would
more hard candy like if you do the hard
candy like it's gonna be delicious and
it's gonna take a long time to dissolve
in your mouth it's kind of like a kind
of like a jawbreaker like you're gonna
be working on each one for like five
minutes before it dissolves and it'll be
really good if you go that route though
again temperature is very important get
it up to 300 / 149 Celsius it's going to
form a nice hard candy and be nice if
you get it up to 302 or 150 degrees
Celsius then it's gonna be nasty because
the smoke point of butter is 302 or 150
and if you get butter above its smoke
point it's just gonna impart even more
of a bitter flavor and might be
unpleasant so temperature control is
really important there but if you go
this route if you make caramels which
I'd strongly recommend you do so just go
with like the basic candy version first
it's really really good I've talked
about this too long but my god they're
delicious and I love caramel they're
very good
one of these days have you talked about
sour dough on the show yet so I'm going
to okay yeah I'm gonna say one of these
days we have to because it sounds like
you perfected your recipe dude you need
to try slice when we go back down I will
so yeah I I've I've been getting more
into baking and once I felt like I had a
really good handle on like commercially
yeasted dough's I've been getting more
into sour dough I've tried it before and
my prior experiences didn't go well this
time around it's going quite well I've
made quite a few really good loaves the
issue I had is I really really liked
like an intense sour sour dough flavor
and the loaves coming out before tasted
good but like pretty mild I finally got
the sourness on point since your
starters kind of a living substance and
not as predictable as commercial yeast I
want to get in like three straight
really good loaves before I feel like
I've mastered it enough to talk about it
on the
Podcast but that's coming one of these
days definitely awesome well that does
it for the first episode of season two
of the podcast we are gonna be back in
two weeks
so a little trick for everybody if you
listen to half of this week and half the
next week then you'll be ready to go
when the next episodes out well if
they're listening to this recommendation
they've already made it all the way
through that's a very good point just
for future reference though I think a
lot of people probably listen to the
last 30 seconds and then they go back
that's a normal way to listen to a
podcast I think that's how most people
read books too
yeah you don't want any surprises so
yeah that's how people should watch Game
of Thrones just just to realize the
whole thing's a [ __ ] waste of time I
was gonna say that would not be good for
the show I saw an analysis or like like
uh I guess an expression talking about
like basically a destination can be so
bad that it invalidates the journey and
I've never seen a description of the
last season of Game of Thrones that apt
and on the nose
you know I saw season one of a show
called money heist and I thought it the
whole thing was like really enjoyable
and the end was so bad but I was like
you know I had a good time for about 98%
of that so I I felt differently I was
like oh that was a wild ride that took
me to a very bad place but okay that
does it for this week's episode as
always thank you for listening and we
will see you in two weeks thanks for
listening to the stronger by science
podcast now Greg and I are not experts
in medicine or health or really anything
else for that matter so before you make
any changes to your diet and exercise
habits make sure you check with a doctor
or another healthcare professional if
you enjoyed this podcast and you'd like
to support it
visit stronger by science com to check
out the products and services that we
offer thanks for listening and we'll see
you next time
[Music]
[Music]
you